et pour en parler nous sommes avec
anthony cahier policiers secrétaire
national de la cgt à l'intérieur bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur le
plateau de rtl france pour commencer en
ce 45e jour de grève
au bout de plus d'un an de protestation
des gilet jaune je le disais le moral
des policiers semblent au plus bas avec
le suicide lundi d'une agent de police à
saint nazaire igpn a été saisie
comment quelle est la situation au sein
des commissariats comment réagissent les
politiques et les niveaux on peut
constater alors on est malheureusement
déjà au troisième suicide depuis le
début de l'année donc on peut constater
que le moral des troupes est au plus bas
et qu'il n'a pas changé depuis 2019 mais
ça on peut tout à fait le comprendre
puisque aucune mesure n'a été mise en
place par le gouvernement
mise à part une pseudo cellule d'écouté
a été mise en place par notre ministre
de tutelle mais qui ne répond bien
évidemment pas à la crise qui qui
gangrène la police nationale aujourd'hui
d'accord qu'est-ce qui est mis en place
que ce qui est ce qu'il faudrait mettre
en place aujourd'hui pour soutenir
psychologiquement les policiers un qui
pourrait si vous voulez les policiers
les gens qui ont besoin d'un soutien
psychologique c'est parce qu'il ya une
souffrance il ya des causes à ça et donc
il faut traiter ses causes c'est pas la
peine de mettre des psys dans tous les
commissariats de france si la cause
n'est pas traitée ce qu'il faut c'est
traiter la cause est ce qu'il faut c'est
effectivement rené des redonner du sens
à ce métier
cette semaine le ministre de l'intérieur
a appuyé les forces de l'ordre à
l'exemplarité et au sens de l'éthique
lors des manifestations qu'est ce que
cela révèle selon vous un manque de
soutien de castel
non c'est pas un manque de soutien de la
part du ministre d'ailleurs je ne suis
pas sûr que les forces de l'ordre
demandent à être soutenus par leur
ministre les forces de leur demandais ce
que les policiers demandent c'est
pouvoir faire leur métier de façon
normale c'est-à-dire avec des moyens
matériels mais aussi surtout des moyens
humains et une définition est un rôle du
métier qu'on leur demande de faire et ça
aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus aujourd'hui
c'est par exemple sur les maintien de
l'ordre ce que c'est surtout je pense à
ce type de mission que vous pensez on a
pu de doctrine d'emploi depuis un an
donc
il s'est passé des choses graves dans ce
pays il ya eu des blessés beaucoup de
blessés parmi les manifestants beaucoup
de blessés parmi les policiers
le gouvernement ne s'est toujours plus
ou moins ému des blessés côté policier
jamais du côté des manifestants et
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'ils
aient une espèce de prise de conscience
au bout de 43 jours de grève
alors est ce qu'il ya un lien de cause à
effet je serais tenter de vous dire que
oui effectivement je pense que la grève
est en train de peser que le
gouvernement est en train de
sérieusement gratter la tête et queue il
joue il joue aujourd'hui la carte de
l'apaisement pour vous le fait que le
gouvernement soit plus du côté des
policiers que des manifestants au niveau
des violences ou mon teint lisse
s'adresse à un fossé entre les deux
alors ça aussi c'est un peu biaisé sait
faire des raccourcis
il n'est pas du côté des policiers le
gouvernement 1 quand ils leur font faire
70 heures par semaine tous les samedis
monter sur les champs elysées affronter
les manifestants c'est pas être du côté
des policiers sens et dans la
communication
le gouvernement se veut être proche de
sa police mais dans les faits il est
absolument pas on en a pour l'instant
aucune réformes envisageables qui
pourrait conditionner une amélioration
des conditions de travail on a
aujourd'hui un projet de loi scélérat
sur les retraites qui va très fortement
impacté les policiers qui va leur
demander de travailler entre sept et dix
ans de plus dans leur carrière avec une
baisse de leur pension c'est aujourd'hui
tout à fait inacceptable donc on ne peut
pas dire que le gouvernement protège ces
policiers aujourd'hui c'est pas vrai et
pourtant vous avez obtenu en décembre
dernier le fait que votre régime
dérogatoire ne change pas c'est
totalement faux c'est une information
qui est total france mr christophe
castaner allons qui est totalement
erronée christophe castaner a dans un
premier temps maintenu l'ouverture des
droits à 52 ans et pour les policiers
avec décote et donc ce qui veut dire
qu'un policier qui voudraient faire
valoir ses droits à 52 ans partirait
avec une pension de 600 à 700 euros par
mois personne ne peut vivre avec une une
pension aussi petit et en plus on s'est
aperçu en recevant le projet de loi
qu'en fait c'était pas cinquante deux
ans mais ce serait 57 ans l'âge minimum
toujours avec décote
voilà mais par contre on perd tout le
reste à dire qu'on perd notre statut
actifs
on perd notre régime spécifique à notre
statut spécial on perd notre
bonification du un cinquième qui serait
plus ou moins
remplacé par un une surcotisation de
l'état mais pour l'instant on n'a aucune
preuve de ça rien n'est mis en avant il
n'y a aucun décret qui a été publié donc
aujourd'hui on est impactée à 100% par
ce projet de loi dont vous êtes toujours
dans l'incertitude face à cette réforme
des retraites merci beaucoup merci au
nikaïa je rappelle que vous êtes
policier secrétaire national de la cgt
merci d'avant bourse de vienne question